hi and welcome back to visual politic
I'm grant and in keeping with the theme
of the channel I'm wearing a ridiculous
shirt and I have no hair you're all
welcome this video is brought to you by
news voice the news is broken
almost all US media is owned by just a
handful of big corporations fake news is
obviously a huge problem as well and
finding something unbiased can be hard
news voice is revolutionising the news
landscape is an app that gives you a
personalized news feed by aggregating
major news sites as well as
international and independent media
giving some much-needed balance each
news story shows multiple sources which
are all tagged with their biases and
perspective the news affects almost
every part of our lives what we hear and
read shapes which people we trust what
we eat what we buy how we vote even how
we think news voice is created by us
readers so you can upvote stories that
you find interesting some more people
will see them is essentially a
democratized platform for news plus it
saves you time you get all the news and
all the sources in one app so that you
can be better informed oh and it's
totally free which I appreciate being as
I am Scottish anyway get started with
news voice today for free through the
link below it's available on both Google
Play and the App Store let's get into
the video
[Applause]
[Music]
when communism reached Mother Russia
one of the main superpowers of the 20th
century suddenly emerged the Soviet
Union seven decades of existence
summarized into a single party policy
five-year economic plans the victory
against Nazi Germany the Cold War
against capitalism and of course some
events from the 1980s that they'd rather
forget
Afghanistan Chernobyl and the fall of
the Berlin Wall all came to be symbols
of its final collapse luckily we're
talking about Russia
vodka is plentiful it does help you
forget mr. Gorbachev tear down this wall
[Applause]
however from the rubble of the USSR the
Union of Soviet Socialist Republics
emerged 15 independent republics 15
republics the Soviet propaganda
presented as the 20th century's modern
family but with less comedy and more
hammer and sickle action in the end
these Republic's would end up having
more quarrels and debts between them
than the families and Game of Thrones
and now here comes Vladimir Putin who's
been vindicating Russia's leadership in
the post-soviet space with an
organization to rival the European Union
this organization has a name the
Eurasian Economic Union
and the first thing you want to know is
who belongs to this organization is all
the countries of the former Soviet Union
well sadly for Putin yet no but this
doesn't mean that he anticipates
anything less than the reconstruction of
the Soviet Union the valleys of Portland
Abbey I mean it's a mile each new you
know Mariah homologated Tirana drew
gusto initiative the toolkit series
which is usually of Nutini conflictive
as muslim Nam lunatic and Philip the
Soviet Union disappeared around
Christmas 1991 just two years after I
was born
you're welcome but here's a question
then your family ever argue at Christmas
parties of course it it my definitely
dead whisky will do that well the
Kremlin's case is quite similar family
is still family
[Music]
Russia has tried to be more Mother
Russia than ever and has gathered for
other former Soviet republics to form
the Eurasian Economic Union Kazakhstan
Belarus Kyrgyzstan and Armenia but what
about the remaining republics well
they're a mixed bag first of all we have
Lithuania Latvia and Estonia these three
Baltic republics are like those
relatives who migrated made some money
dead quite well and well now they don't
want to know anything about their
previous life then there are the three
countries that compromise the so-called
Eastern Association of the European
Union Ukraine Georgia and Moldova three
countries that have free trade
agreements with the European bloc and
the dream or well they used to dream of
being able to become full members of the
EU someday
in that same Club we can find Azerbaijan
one of Europe's most important energy
partners which as we told you recently
here on visual politic is stuck in a
kind of permanent conflict or war
against Armenia well the fact is that
these four countries would love to
follow the Baltic republics example but
Europe well it just turns a deaf ear
lastly we have the rest of the Central
Asian countries Turkmenistan is the
crazy member of the family and as we saw
in this video
who lives practically under total
international isolation the last two
whose Becca Stan and Tajikistan have a
bit of a problem they don't really get
along so it seems unlikely that the
Eurasian Economic Union will succeed in
attracting the tatics after news like
this whose Becca stand to become
observer in Russia led Eurasian Economic
Union the point is that as an observer
or a kind of partner country that aims
to cooperate with the alliance with
Becca Stan sides with Moldova which is
ruined tired of waiting for Brussels and
is again looking at Moscow to see what
they could bring to the table but at
this point the question is why exactly
does the Eurasian Economic Union consist
of - why extent is Russia are pulling
the strings and even more importantly in
this community ever becomes something
similar to the European Union today on
visual politic we are going to answer
all these questions but first here's a
bit of history
growing pains the Eurasian Economic
Union has had a difficult birth and the
growing pains haven't stopped think
about this how many times have you heard
that the Paris Berlin access drives the
European Union Lots I thought so in fact
that's where its origin lies the
European Union was born out of the need
for two countries namely Germany and
France to cooperating to build a shared
future after a century of engaging in
one war after another
however the starting point of the
post-soviet space is very very different
completely different in fact
[Music]
three-quarters of the territory of the
former USSR make up the current Russian
Federation and Russia alone has more
inhabitants than the other fourteen
republics put together obviously we can
see how any organization assembled from
these would dance to Moscow's beat
[Music]
and of course as you can imagine this
tactic frightens the former Soviet
republics what all these countries want
is to continue to command themselves not
to receive orders from Moscow ever again
this fear has a lot to do with this
organization's growing pains let's go
back to 2004 the European Union opened
its doors to Eastern Europe in 2004 an
expansion that weakened Russia's
geopolitical position in two important
ways first the Kremlin had to witness
the entry of the Baltic republics three
former member territories of the Soviet
Union into the European Union and second
Poland Hungary the Czech Republic and
Slovakia also joined the European family
and after a few more years Bulgaria and
Romania - this constituted a switching
of signs from practically all the
countries that were once part of the
Warsaw Pact a symbol of the hegemonic
power of the USSR over the communist
bloc
well this is what's triggered the
Kremlin's efforts to create an
organization its own organization to try
and rebuild this post-soviet space and
of course what was the second most
important Republic in the former Soviet
Union Ukraine so based on the Russian
approach the Moscow Kiev axis would be
something like the Paris Berlin axis and
its ability to lead the new block this
would reduce the feeling that what
Moscow wants is literally to gobble up
the rest
so in sensible write Moscow Kiev at the
head of a new international block what
could go wrong hold on because there is
a problem Ukraine
never wanted to have anything to do with
this project and listen carefully
because this push and pull between the
interests of one group and the other
caused no less than two revolutions in
Ukraine the first was the Orange
Revolution
you see Ukraine's 2004 presidential
election that its Prime Minister Viktor
Yanukovych from Ukraine's eastern
regions and clearly pro-russian against
the pro-european opponent Viktor
Yushchenko who is in favor of Ukraine
joining NATO at first Yanukovych won but
the opposition immediately denounced as
electoral fraud triggering the strong
popular protest that led to the Orange
Revolution in the end the judiciary
ordered new elections to behold and Gavi
Shenko prevailed
well we've already mentioned that things
on this side of the world are almost as
hectic as in Game of Thrones just with
fewer dragons and more bears the
coalition that supported EF Schenkel
quickly collapsed and his government
ended up being quite a disappointment
even though this was around the time
when Ukraine joined Eastern Partnership
of the European Union besides that well
practically nothing happened
and that's how Yanukovych won the 2010
elections and the timing was perfect
with a pro-russian in Kiev the Kremlin
began to pull the strings to promote a
regional organization first they
launched a customs union between Russia
Kazakhstan and Belarus a union which
Ukraine would soon join according to the
Kremlin's plans but there was a problem
the problem is that things in Ukraine
continued to get complicated and
everything worsened when President
Yanukovych decided to stop negotiating
with the European Union to reach an
association and free trade agreement and
thus leave the way clear to join the
block the Russia LED that's how the Euro
Maidan revolution broke out and you know
what happened Yanukovych fled to Russia
for this time the Kremlin did not
systemic considered on a second Oh
premium stuff I see the Republic Ukraine
Aguada see what's going you know how
things are in eastern Ukraine there are
rebel guerillas supported by Moscow and
yes this might have caused Russia's
relations with the European Union and
the United States to worsen but at the
same time putin sent a very powerful
message to the other X Soviet republics
either you're with me or you know what
can happen
just two months later the treaty that
created the Eurasian Economic Union was
Saint listen up five countries five
objectives after the rocky start that
the Eurasian Economic Union suffered
another main problem that the
organization faces is the lack of common
purpose because each of the five
countries that compromise the union has
its own objectives and believe me when I
tell you that they are very different
for example Russia's agenda is the most
obvious regional economic integration
has become the formula to boost
prosperity that way it will get a
broader and more stable market for its
own products besides as we mentioned
before leading such an organization in
post-soviet space is very useful for the
Kremlin and helps their objective of
reinforcing Russia's global position the
return of Mother Russia
[Music]
none of this entails any kind of revival
of the Soviet Union it would be naive to
try to revive or emulate something that
has been consigned to history but these
times call for close integration based
on new values and a new political and
economic foundation we suggest a
powerful supranational association
capable of becoming one of the poles in
the modern world and serving as an
efficient bridge between Europe and the
dynamic asia-pacific region Vladimir
Putin in 2011 I know in this political
game the most important role that had
ever once been reserved for Ukraine has
fallen to Kazakhstan because when the
Eurasian Economic Union was launched in
Kazakhstan had a good reason to be
cautious a quarter of Kazakhstan's
population is a Russian ethnicity and
that means that the pretext Putin used
to annex Crimea you know the thing about
protecting Russian citizens and
russian-speaking people could also apply
there but just a second because unlike
Ukraine Kazakhstan also had two aces up
his sleeve
first they know that Russia had an
urgent need to lead a regional bloc
after suffering significant sanctions
from the West due to the occupation of
Crimea secondly Kazakhstan has
alternatives thanks to its geographical
location China holds strong investments
in the country and is currently its main
trading partner
so while Crimea had an important
incentive to get along with Putin let's
say that Kazakhstan wasn't as concerned
enough to say yes to everything and that
that changed the whole story let me
explain
Russia's initial intentions for the
post-soviet space were to establish a
more comprehensive Union that
encompassed a unified monetary regime as
well as defense and political
integration sound familiar this
extensive plan was rejected by
Kazakhstan which was determined to
prioritize the economic aspect for this
reason it blocked Russia's suggestions
to prevent the UAE with capabilities in
foreign policy coordination border
defense visa policies medical care and
education Kazakhstan also rejected
Russia's claim to establish a Eurasian
Parliament and made it clear that it
would not give up a smidge of its
sovereignty by joining the Union
it's been five years since President
Nazarbayev established the Kazakh
possession before the Union and his
successor president Pocoyo has made it
just as clear the EI EU is an economic
project without a political dimension it
is a partnership of sovereign nations
whose focuses on how to improve the
environment for businesses and
investment and remove barriers to trade
both within member countries and from
its outside partners assume Jo Mart
Tokai EV president of Kazakhstan for
their part Belarus Kazakhstan and
Armenia also have their reasons for
joining the Union because unlike
Kazakhstan they aren't rich in natural
resources so Russia's promises of oil
and gas mates rates have been a good way
to attract in other words offering them
cheaper energy resources and a larger
market to sell their heavy machinery
while maintaining Russian cooperation
were good enough reasons to join in fact
Belarus has been under Moskos orbit
practically since as independence as
we've explained in another video there's
even a plan to integrate both countries
then Forex Park Kazakhstan whose economy
depends on the re exportation of Chinese
products has already seen from the
beginning that the customs union that
had been formed was limiting its
possibilities so they joined the
Eurasian Union without much trouble
of course Russia already knew how to
convince them Russia to allocate 1.2
billion to help kyrgyzstan join customs
union and finally Armenia wanted to
strengthen his position in the face of
the conflict that maintains with his
neighbor a cerveza
both countries are Russia's military
partners and Armenia tried to tip the
balance by strengthening its ties to the
Kremlin of course so far it hasn't
really worked well that covers how the
Eurasian Economic Union emerged and what
motivated to the five member countries
to join what having reached this point
many of you may be thinking okay grant
okay but after five years of operation
why exactly have they achieved what
future awaits them well listen up Moscow
is still a long way from Brussels
if the Eurasian Economic Union wanted to
look anything like the 1991 Soviet Union
has already succeeded they work just as
an efficient way after five years the
general feeling is that this
organization is far from meeting its
expectations and the question is why
well mostly because it's still nothing
more than an organization made by
countries that were already trading with
each other and what's worse with
economies that compete with each other
at many production levels
furthermore Russia's dominance in this
particular Union brings an additional
problem if the Russian economy sneezes
the Eurasian Union catches our really
really bad cold when the original
Customs Union was launched in 2011 the
wind was blowing in his favor and the
price of oil was high the Russian and
Kazakh economies were growing and
Belarus was also benefiting from it
but when the Eurasian Economic Union
started operating in 2015 Russia was
already in a crisis after a drop in the
price of oil and due to the Western
sanctions following the annexation of
Crimea a crisis from which it hasn't yet
recovered since then the Russian economy
still hasn't fully picked up and the
least of its concerns is to fill its
markets with the products of its
partners from the Eurasian Economic
Union
and this this has strong consequences
for the other members because trade with
Russia represents no less than 96% of
all the trades held within the Eurasian
Union basically more than a union
between countries as a union between
countries that trade with Russia
[Music]
for example as you can see for Belarus
trade with Russia accounts for almost
half of all its foreign trade and as for
the rest of the members the situation
isn't really that different
however unlike these member countries
for Russia reciprocal trade barely
represents 8% of its commercial
portfolio in other words from an
economic point of view for Moscow this
Alliance isn't as important as initially
thought furthermore the idea of having a
common market is far from being achieved
there are still many protected sectors
that remain outside the economic union
and even in some sectors that were
supposed to have new barriers countries
frequently under trade to defend their
national producers cycling all kinds of
administrative and technical reasons
such as sanatorium veterinary controls
[Music]
they are trying to solve this but
there's still a long way to go when it
comes down to it things are going very
very slowly
for example the creation of the common
electricity market has been postponed
until at least 2025 a single oil and
natural gas market is also planned for
that year will that deadline ever be met
well we don't know but what we do know
is that Russia isn't very interested and
that makes us suspect that today the
questions are more important than the
answers so why isn't Russia interested
well
because energy policy is an essential
asset and Russia's foreign policy that's
right its foreign policy I don't think
this really comes as any news to anyone
Russia does both business and politics
with its natural resources here's an
example since the Armenian government
doesn't like Putin very much
last year the gas price was raised by 10
percent and as we outlined in a video
that we made in February 20 20 is using
its oil to pressure Belarus into
promoting the union between both
countries but to be fair not everything
is bad news the truth is that the
Eurasian Union has also had some
positive results for example the free
movement of workers has alleviated
Armenia and kersek stands international
situation says now they're unemployed
citizens have more accessibility to work
opportunities and a new life although is
a new life in Russia and this regulatory
change has been beneficial for everyone
on the one hand Russia which has an
aging population gets Labor and on the
other migrants from Armenia and
Kazakhstan send billions of dollars home
from Russia each year
also on the positive side we find the
signing of free trade agreements they
have done this with countries as diverse
as Egypt Serbia Vietnam and Singapore
furthermore the Eurasian Economic Union
has also signed a trade cooperation
agreement with China and that isn't the
only regional power with which they have
strengthened times listen up
Iran EA you free trade agreement to take
place in two or three years official of
course this commercial open doors policy
could be a life length for this
organization which is so far being how
can I say it inconsequential anyway
having reached this point the question
is what future do you foresee for the
Eurasian Economic Union can it
consolidate as a union and strengthen
the economic and even political
integration of its member states will it
be a tool for progress or will it simply
anchor Russia's power and influence
leave your answers as always in the
comments below we really hope you
enjoyed this episode of how you hope you
like all our videos in fact if you do
you can always click down there you can
like and subscribe don't forget to check
back you can find our new videos every
week if you click the little bell you'll
get a little notification when they pop
up also don't forget to check out our
friends at the reconsidered media
podcast they provided the vocals in this
episode but we're not my dulcet tones
finally this channel is possible because
of patreon and our supporters on that
platform please consider joining them
and supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage and as
always see you in the next video if you
want to learn more about politics and
world affairs and here's some more of my
lovely voice come check out the
reconsidered podcast where we don't do
the thinking for you find reconsider @ww
re consider mediacom or on Apple or
Google Play or your favorite podcast
[Music]